-Rudy Giuliani admitted
in a deposition
that he didn´t try to verify
his insane voter fraud lies,
and Ted Cruz decided to pick
a fight with Big Bird.
For more on this,
it´s time for "A Closer Look."
♫♫
If you have opened Twitter
or flipped past cable news
on your TV in the past week,
you´ve probably heard
that Democrats
lost an election in Virginia
and won an election
in New Jersey,
where Governor Phil Murphy
became the first Democrat
to win reelection
since the 1970s.
So of course, on cue, the usual
suspects are once again
claiming there was fraud.
-In New Jersey, I -- Now,
the guy hasn´t conceded, right?
Because we´re going
to do a big foren--
I think they´re going
to do a big audit
is what I´ve been hearing
on the ground
because these votes
came in, 40,000 votes,
they´re not real.
They´re not real.
We´ve been getting flood.
I´ve been getting floods of
texts on my phone
and e-mails going,
"They did it again.
They did it in New Jersey."
Now remember,
they still cheated in Virginia,
even though the Republican won.
But for some reason there,
they didn´t do the big jump
in the middle of the night.
Maybe it would have been
too obvious to steal two horses
at the same time.
You know, I don´t know.
-Lindell really comes to you
with the energy
of a sugared-up kid on Halloween
telling you about his day.
"We saw a ghost and a skeleton,
and then there was --
Wait, wait, another ghost
and Kevin was there,
but he fell down and cried,
Everybody, we got so much
candy!"
But, okay, a couple of things.
First of all,
thanks for clearing up
that you´ve been getting flooded
with texts on your phone,
you know, as opposed to texts
that you get in the mail
or the ones you can
get it Marshalls
and put up on your wall.
Second, these guys love audits,
not to be confused with "aw
dis," which is what people say
when Mike Lindell
enters a room.
"Aw, dis ass[bleep]."
"I thought two horses
dumped ballots in the road,
but it was just
regular horse dumps."
Also, what do you mean
they cheated in Virginia,
but not enough to win?
Why would they do that?
That would be like if the Jets
hacked the scoreboard
so instead of losing to
the Colts 45-30 last Thursday,
they lost 45-32.
And that´s right,
this is important.
The Jets did lose on Thursday,
which stopped them
from having
a two-game win streak,
which is good for "Late Night"
because we need easy punch lines
about the Jets sucking.
Though, it is bad for our crew,
almost all of whom
are Jets fans,
and that´s not by accident.
If you want to surround yourself
with loyal people
who aren´t going to bail
when things get tough,
get people who are still
sticking with the Jets.
They are so easy to please.
For crew snack yesterday,
we just put out
loose slices of ham,
and I heard one of them say,
"Still better
than Mark Sanchez."
Anyway, we´ve long known
from all the court cases
the lack of evidence,
and, you know, reality
that the people
who keep insisting
there was widespread voter fraud
in the 2020 election
are unhinged maniacs and liars.
But now,
thanks to a new court case,
we know from their own words
that they knew
what they were saying
might not be true
because in a newly
released deposition,
former Trump lawyer
Rudy Giuliani
essentially admitted he had
no evidence for his voter fraud
claims because he didn´t have
time to verify them.
-New video exclusive to CNN
shows Donald Trump´s
allies saying under oath that
they put very little effort
into verifying debunked claims
of election fraud
before spreading them
on the national stage.
-Before the press conference,
I was told about it.
Sometimes I go and look myself
on line when stuff comes up.
This time I don´t have
the time to do it.
It´s not my job in
a fast-moving case to go out
and investigate every piece
of evidence that´s given to me.
-No, of course not.
That´s what lawyers are for.
As everyone knows, you´re just
the events coordinator
for a landscaping company.
Oh, Rudy. Rudy, sweet Rudy,
that is your job.
I mean, it was supposed
to be your job.
Although in fairness,
Rudy looks less like a guy
who would investigate a crime
and more like the guy
sitting on a park bench
who just tells the cops
what they´re doing is wrong.
"You think the pickpocket
went that way?
Well, then best of luck to you.
If I were the pickpocket,
I´d sit right here
on this bench.
Whoa, what´s with the cuffs?"
And it doesn´t surprise me
that he didn´t do any vetting
right before
his infamous press conference
with fellow crazy person
Sidney Powell
since during that
press conference,
he was sweating like a guy
who knew his facts
might not be rock solid.
My man is perspiring
like he just bet his life
savings on a horse
called The Three-Legged Rocket.
You really don´t think it´s
your job to verify information
before you announce it
to the world?
Is this how you operated
when you were mayor?
"Thank you for coming to this
press conference, everyone.
I have huge news
for the city of New York.
Today, I received an e-mail
with the subject line
´FWD: FWD: FWD:
Free Boner Pills for Life!´
And that´s not just for me,
it´s the life
of this entire city.
And in return, all I had to do
was give them
our Social Security numbers,
but only the first nine digits."
Rudy seems so tired
in that deposition.
And I get it.
It´s exhausting just watching
someone be that crazy.
I can´t imagine what it´s like
to live a day to day.
That´s the thing about
the modern Republican Party.
They just make
everything exhausting.
It´s so hard to follow
their insane voter fraud claims
or their latest
culture war obsessions.
Every day, it seems like we have
to endure one dumb culture war
controversy after another.
And that´s before we even
get to the war on Christmas
because, you know, it´s coming.
When Trump was president,
they claim Christmas was saved,
but now the Democrats
are in charge again.
You know they´re going to find
some school district
somewhere that calls them
"holiday decorations"
instead of
Christmas decorations.
And Jeanine Pirro is going
to spend the entire hour
on her show rage guzzling
two bottles of Charles Shaw.
She probably calls them Chuck.
And while we´re on the subject
we brought up for no reason,
I´m not pro war on Christmas,
but I wouldn´t mind negotiating
a peace treaty
that gets it to stick
to reasonable calendar borders.
I mean, it´s encroaching
on the other holidays.
There are people out there
who start putting up
Christmas decorations
the day after Halloween.
The other day
I saw an animatronic skeleton
on someone´s porch
wearing a Santa hat,
and now my kids think
Santa is dead.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway.
Oh, which reminds me
tonight´s "Closer Look"
is brought to you
by the word "Anyway."
Need a way back
to the political stuff
after a long tangent?
Try "anyway."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, we had to endure one
nauseatingly stupid culture
war controversy after another,
like when conservatives started
whining about
Potato Head pronouns
or said Joe Biden was going
to steal your hamburgers.
And when they lost their minds
over the Dr. Seuss estate
voluntarily pulling
a few books from publication
that no one cared about anyway.
-Say goodbye to your burgers
if you want to sign up
for the Biden climate agenda.
-Americans would have to
cut red meat consumption
by a whopping 90%.
-He wants to cut out 90%
of the red meat
that you all eat.
-First, they outlaw Dr. Seuss,
and now they want to tell us
what to say.
-Look out, Mr. Potato Head,
you´re next.
-They want to cancel
the Muppets.
They want to cancel
Mr. and Mrs. Potato Head.
-You see, last week
they tried to cancel
Kermit the Frog
and Mr. Potato Head?
You see that?
-This week alone,
they canceled Mr. Potato Head.
You know, this week alone,
they canceled the Muppets.
You know, they´re canceling
Dr. Seuss.
-Alright. First of all,
Mr. Potato Head isn´t canceled.
He was just on TV.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Whoa, hold on a second.
Can´t we change his mouth?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Horrifying, but also
a little bit better.
Obviously, none of that stuff
was canceled or outlawed,
but they have to keep
the culture wars burning
because they have nothing else
to talk about.
So every week
it´s something new.
Potato Head, Dr. Seuss,
"Looney Tunes."
Next, they´re going to claim the
left is canceling Sandra Boynton
because she refused
to include the hippopotamus
and now the hippos are so mad
they´re showing up to school
board meetings going berserk.
Any Sandra Boynton fans
in the house?!
[ Scattered
cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Wish I had a way out of this.
Oh, I do.
Anyway...
And now, like clockwork,
the right has come up
with their next culture war
target -- Big Bird.
-Big Bird and the backlash that
the "Sesame Street" character
is getting from
some Republicans
after tweeting he got the COVID
shot over the weekend.
-The "Sesame Street" character,
who is six years old
on the show,
posted about getting the vaccine
after the Pfizer shot
was approved
for kids as young as five.
-Big Bird is literally hawking
an unnecessary vaccine
for children.
Big Bird is literally
encouraging children
to take a vaccine scientifically
that they do not need.
-A lot of propaganda
about the vaccines
being not directed
to the parents,
not information given to parents
so they can make that decision,
but really getting it
directly to the kids
in some really creepy ways,
including "Sesame Street."
-Texas Senator Ted Cruz
responded to Big Bird´s tweet,
saying, "Government propaganda
for your five year old."
-Oh, my God. So in the end,
it turns out
they were the ones who
-...canceled The Muppets.
[ Echoing ]
[ Sinister music playing ]
♫♫
-But seriously [laughs] I have
to admit, it´s a tough one.
I mean,
who are you going to side with?
The beloved
and iconic children´s character
widely celebrated
for over half a century
by people of all ages
and backgrounds
from all parts of the world,
or a widely disliked
wannabe werewolf with
the charm of a serial killer
and the voice of a dying barn
owl who was once called
"Lucifer in the flesh"
by one of his fellow Republicans
after another fellow Republican
joked he was so unpopular
you could murder him
and get away with it?
Uh...could be either --
I don´t know.
These people´s brains
are so weird.
They wake up in the morning
and think it´s a good idea
to go to war with Big Bird.
Next, they´re
going to claim Moderna
is how the Swedish Chef
says "my dinner."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I´m going to do it.
[ Clears throat ]
"Hey, Swedish Chef,
what are you doing?"
"I´m-a makin´ moderna."
And that -- Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, I mean, can´t --
Can´t stop that.
And that´s today´s
topical joke for kids.
We want "Closer Look" to be
something you can safely watch
with your whole family.
Now where was I?
Oh, right.
This [bleep] guy.
Seriously, though,
that´s what Republicans
are focused on -- stoking dumb
culture war controversies,
fanning anti-vaccine sentiment,
and spreading false claims
about voter fraud.
And now we know that even they
knew those claims were lies.
It turns out they were so full
of it they had to take a...
-...big dump
in the middle of the night.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♫♫
God´s Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you´re watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.